If you think much about physics and
cognition and intelligence,
it's pretty obvious the human mind is
not the smartest possible general
intelligence and you more than humans
are the highest jumpers are the fastest
runners.
We're not going to be the smartest
thinkers if you are going to work toward
agi rather than focusing on some narrow
application.
There's a number of different approaches
that you might take and I've spent some
time just surveying the Agi field as a
whole and organizing an annual
conference on their gi.
And then I've spent a bunch of more time
on a specific agi approach,
which is based on the open cog open
source software platform in the big
picture.
One way to approach Agi is to try to
emulate the human brain at some level of
precision,
and this is the approach I see.
For example,
Google deep mind taking.
They've taken deep neural networks,
which in their common form are mostly a
model of visual and auditory processing
in the human brain.
And now in the recent work such as the
DNC differential neuro computer,
they're taking these deep networks that
model visual or auditory processing and
their coupling that with a memory matrix
which models some aspect of what the
hippocampus does,
which is the part of the brain that
deals with working memory,
short term memory among other things.
So this illustrates an approach where
you take neural networks emulating
different parts of the brain and maybe
you take more and more in the neural
networks and building different parts of
the human brain.
You try to get them to all work
together,
not necessarily doing computational
neuroscience,
but trying to emulate the way different
parts of the brain are doing processing
and the way they're talking to each
other.
A totally different approach is being
taken by a guy named Marcus hooter in
Australian National University.
He wrote a beautiful book on Universal
Ai in which he showed how to write a
superhuman infinitely intelligence
thinking machine and like 50 lines of
code.
The problem is it would take more
computing power than there is in the
entire universe to run.
So it's so,
it's not practically useful,
but they're then trying to scale down
from this theoretical Agi to find
something that that will really work.
Now the approach we're taking in the
open cog project is different than
either of those we're attempting to
emulate at a very high level.
The way the human mind seems to work as
an embodied social,
generally intelligent agent,
which is coming to grips with hard
problems in the context of coming to
grips with itself and its and its life
in the world.
We're not drawing the model the way the
brain works at the level of neurons and
neural networks.
We're looking at the human mind more
from a high level cognitive point of
view.
What kinds of of memory are there?
Well,
there's semantic memory about abstract
knowledge or concrete facts.
There's episodic memory of our other
biographical history,
their sensory motor memory.
There's associative memory of things
that have been related to us in our
lives.
There's procedural memory of how to do
things and we then look at the different
kinds of learning and reasoning the
human mind can do.
We can do logical deduction sometimes.
We're not always good at it.
We date,
we make emotional intuitive leaps and
strange creative combinations of things
we learned by trial and error and habit.
We learned socially by imitating,
mirroring,
emulating or opposing others,
these different kinds of memory and
learning that the human mind has.
One can attempt to achieve each of those
where the cutting edge computer science
algorithm rather than trying to achieve
each of those functions and structures
and the way the brain does.
So what we have in open cog,
we have a central knowledge repository,
which is very dynamic and lives in ram
on a large network of computers,
which we call the atom space.
And for,
for the mathematicians or computer
science in the audience,
the Adams space is what you'd call a,
uh,
weighted labeled hypergraph.
So it has nodes,
it has links.
A link can go between two nodes or a
link ego between three,
four,
five or 50 nodes.
Different nodes and links have different
types and the nodes and links can have
numbers attached to them and know your
link could have a weight indicating a
probability or a confidence.
It could have a weight indicating how
important it is to the system right now
or how important it is in the longterm,
so it should be kept around and the
systems memory on this Adam space this
way did labeled hypergraph.
We can have a lot of different ai
processes working together
cooperatively,
so the the atom space,
the memory stores,
what we would call neural symbolic.
That means we can represent nodes and
links that are like neurons in the
brain,
which is fairly low level,
but we can also represent nodes and
links that are higher level representing
pieces of of symbolic logic expressions.
So we can do explicit logical reasoning,
which is pretty abstract and low level
neural net stuff.
In the same hypergraph the same items
space acting on this Adam space.
We have deep neural networks for visual
and auditory perception.
We have a probabilistic logic engine
which does abstract reasoning.
We have an evolutionary learning
algorithm that uses genetic algorithm
type methods to try to evolve radical
new new ideas and concepts and look for
data patterns and we have a neural net
type dynamic that spreads activity and
importance throughout the network.
A few other algorithms,
a pattern mining algorithm that just
scans through the whole admin space
looking for surprising stuff and the
trick is all these different cognitive
algorithms have to work together
cooperatively to help each other rather
than hurt each other.
See the bottleneck in essentially every
ai approach ever taken,
be it a neural net,
a logic engine,
the genetic algorithm,
whatever the bottleneck in every ai
approach ever taken has been what we
call common tutorial explosion.
And what that means is you have a lot of
data items,
you're a lot of perceptions coming into
your eye or you have a lot of possible
moves on the chessboard or a lot of
possible ways to move the wheel of the
car and there's so many combinations of
possible data items and possible things
you could do.
Sifting through all those combinations
becomes an exponential problem.
I mean if,
if you have a thousand things,
there's two to the 1020 a combined them
and that and that's the way to money.
So how the sift through common tutorial
explosions is the core problem everyone
has to deal with in a deep neural
network as currently pursued it solved
by making the network have a very
specific structure which reflects the
structure of visual and auditory
streams.
And in a logic engine you don't have
that sort of luxury because a logic
engine has to deal with anything.
Not,
not just sensory data,
but what we do in open cog is we've
worked out a system where each of the
cognitive processes can help the other
one out when it,
when it gets stuck in some communist
oriel explosion problems.
So if if a deep neural network turning
the perceived things gets confused
because it's dark or it's looking at
something it never saw before,
well maybe the reasoning engine can come
in and do some inference to cut through
that confusion.
If logical reasoning is getting confused
and doesn't know what step to take next
cause there's just so many possibilities
are there.
And not much information about the mall.
Maybe you fish into your sensory motor
memory and you use deep learning to
visualize something you saw before.
And that gives you a clue of how to pair
through the many possibilities that the,
that the logic engine is seeing.
Now you can model this kind of cognitive
synergy mathematically using a branch of
mathematics called category theory,
which is something I've been working on
lately.
But what's really interesting more so is
to build a system that manifests this
and achieves general intelligence as a
result.
And that's what we're doing in the open
card project.
We're not there yet to general
intelligence,
but we're getting there step by step.
We're using our open source open cog
platform to control David Hanson's
beautiful,
incredibly realistic humanoid robots
like this Sophia robot,
which has gotten a lot of media
attention in the last year.
We're using open card to analyze
biological data related to the genetics
of,
of longevity.
And we're doing a host of other
consulting projects using this.
So we're,
we're proceeding on an r and d track and
an application track at at the same
time.
But our end goal with the system is to
use cognitive synergy on our neural
symbolic knowledge store to achieve
initially human level Ai.
But that's just nearly stage goal and
then ai much beyond the human level.
And that is another advantage of taking
an approach that doesn't adhere
slavishly to the human brain.
The brain is pretty good at recognizing
faces because millions of years of
evolution when into that part of the
brain.
But for doing science or math or logical
reasoning,
your strategic planning,
we're pretty bad.
And these are things that we started
doing only recently in evolutionary time
as a result of of modern culture.
So I think actually opened cognitive,
other AI systems have potential to be
far better than,
than human beings at the sort of logical
and strategic side of things.
And I think that's quite important
because if you take a human being and
upgrade them to like 10,000 Iq,
the the,
the outcome might not be what you want
because you,
you've got a motivational system and an
emotional system that basically evolved
in prehuman animals.
Where as if you architect a system where
rationality and and empathy play a
deeper role in the architecture,
then as its intelligence ramps way up,
we may find the more beneficial outcome.